remember a few years ago when we all
discovered that Mitt Romney had an alter
ego Senator Romney we learned went by a
pseudonym
Pierre delecto
and as Pierre delecto Romney liked and
replied to tweets from journalists and
from some of his colleagues in Congress
okay
Well turns out there's another
politician in Washington with a gnome de
plume this time it's President Biden
whose pseudonym is Robert L Peters and
as Robert L Peters President Biden
emailed Hunter Biden's crooked business
associates and scheduled secret phone
calls with the president of Ukraine
while running U.S policy on the Eastern
European nation
a little bit different
very different uses of pseudonyms the
house committee on oversight and
accountability has uncovered Biden's
secret identity which appears to have
been a little bit more focused and a
little bit more lucrative than Mitt
Romney's silly burner account the
committee is actually uncovered that
Biden used multiple pseudonymous
accounts to secretly conduct business
with his son and foreign powers while he
was vice president those other
pseudonyms include Robin Ware jrb Ware
and who knows how many others this fact
might explain why Joe Biden struggles
these days to remember his own name he
has so many of them it's difficult to
keep track also might explain why Joe
Biden managed to forget and deny all of
the times that we now know he heard
about participated in and apparently
profited immensely from all those
crooked business deals
it wasn't him after all it was Robert L
Peters
but something tells me despite the
committee's request for more records
that the executive agencies are going to
continue to Stonewall they're not going
to go after Joe Biden or Robert Peters
or Robin Ware or any other Biden Persona
they're not going to go after the
current president for being a crook
they're too busy Prosecuting the former
president for opposing him a Michael
knowlesist Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show there's some
real anti-marriage propaganda going
around on Tick Tock whether this is
propaganda sent from the Chinese through
Tick Tock or just from insufferable
American leftists we will get to it
first though I've got to turn
my attention to a Republican
back to Congress back to Capitol Hill to
a republican there that this is a
bizarre Saga I was traveling a little
bit the last couple of days and so I'm
just catching up on it now which I'm I'm
glad it actually took me a little while
because there have been some new
developments
over in Ohio
there is a GOP conservative activist and
campaigner by the name of Lizzie Marbach
and she tweeted out this quote
there is no hope for any of us outside
of having faith in Jesus Christ Alone
okay
it's a pretty basic
profession of the Christian faith the
Christian Creed begins I believe in God
the Father Almighty maker of heaven and
Earth and in Jesus Christ his only son
our Lord who is conceived by the Holy
Spirit one of the Virgin Mary suffered
in a Pontius Pilate which crucified died
and was buried the rest of the Creed
goes on and so this is a very very basic
expression of what you believe if you're
a Christian there's no hope for any of
us outside of having faith in Jesus
Christ alone okay
also this is a private citizen
a woman with not very many followers on
Twitter who has worked in politics and
has campaigned and apparently worked for
the Ohio right to life okay
then a sitting Republican congressman
quote tweets this lady
and says this is one of the most bigoted
tweets I have ever seen delete it Lizzy
delete it delete it
Christian
religious freedom in the United States
applies to every religion you've gone
too far
this is one of the most bigoted tweets
I've ever seen this is an insane
completely egregious tweet the
translation of which is
this
profession of Christian faith is one of
the most biggest tweets I've ever seen
delete
your expression of Faith Lizzy religious
freedom in the United States applies to
every religion except for Christianity
apparently you've gone too far okay
so completely insane completely
unacceptable truly truly scandalous
stuff from a sitting member of Congress
Max Miller a republican to boot but
he then recognized his error
so not too long afterward he tweets out
I posted something earlier that conveyed
a message that I did not intend I will
not try to hide my mistake or run from
it I sincerely apologize to Lizzy and to
everyone who read my post I'm really
glad to see this
because he says I sincerely apologize I
was wrong I did something wrong
sorry
and and I'm generally I try to be quick
to accept apologies I try to be slow to
anger and quick to forgive that's in
that's in the Lord's Prayer we please
father forgive us our debts as we
forgive those who trespass against us
but there's a question raised by this
apology it says I posted something
earlier that conveyed a message I did
not intend so the obvious question is
well what message did you intend
this is a pretty blunt tweet so what
message did you intend it would seem
more reasonable to me that he intended
to say exactly what he did said but he
said it in a moment of passion and anger
and irrationality and then he realized
once he had cooled off that what he said
was completely unacceptable and he
regretted it and changed his mind
that that to me it was so it's that
seems much more likely to me the
congressman is more than welcome to come
on the show we can talk about it uh
it's it's a little bit of an ambiguous
apology but still he says I sincerely
apologize I did something wrong the
thing that I said
came out wrong I'm sorry okay
but then this is really troublesome
it broke last night that Lizzie Marbach
the woman who posted this basic
expression of faith has been fired from
her job at Ohio right to life
it also came out that the congressman's
wife is on the board of Ohio right to
life
now I don't know maybe
this gal Lizzie Marbach maybe she really
messed up something in the office
yesterday just coincidentally you know
she poured coffee on the computer all
right you're fired gal but
that seems unlikely to me it seems
likely to me that she was fired in
relation to this tweet this sitting
member of Congress attacking her for the
most basic expression of the Christian
faith I can possibly imagine
and then publicly apologizing but then
she loses her job when the congressman's
wife is on the board of the it really
stinks to high heaven and so now while
previously I would totally accept that
apology and I think we ought to be as
gracious and forgiving as we can be
within reason and within Prudence now I
have to question that apology
I think we need to call attention to
that because it's indicative of a
broader problem in the country which is
we talk a lot about religious freedom we
talk a lot about neutrality and
everyone's welcome to believe whatever
they want but there is a concerted
effort in this country that has gone on
for many many years to stigmatize
Christians and to ostracize them and to
push them out of the Public Square and
to kick Christian beliefs and customs
and rituals out of
classrooms government buildings popular
culture every just everywhere
a big big problem and now when you add
on to that
you've got the FBI infiltrating Catholic
traditional masses when you've got the
the FBI coming in knocking down the
doors of of pro-life activists
knocking on you know the wife opens the
door seven kids there they arrest the
father
for simply following his faith and
protesting against infanticide you see
there is a deeply deeply
anti-christian campaign going on in the
country and I expect it from the libs
but when you see it from a republican
member of Congress that's a big problem
had had the the gal not been fired I'd
say Okay move on accept the apology
because you also want to give people an
off ramp I don't know what motivated
this guy Max Miller to send his tweet
maybe he was really tired he was
overworked he was drunk I have no idea
but I've said plenty of things that I
that I come to regret or that I didn't
even believe at the time so I'm totally
willing to extend Grace but there needs
to be an explanation for why this woman
lost her job because right now
[Music]
does not look good does not look and it
would seem to be part of a broader
campaign
to attack Christians in the United
States which is a Christian Nation which
has been founded from the very very
beginning
to be a Christian Nation without which
Christian Soul without which Christian
spirit
the country in the words of our own
founding fathers the country doesn't
make any sense the country can't work we
got to talk about these things when you
want to talk to your friends you got to
check out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles you know a company
is looking out for you when they upgrade
your service and don't charge you for it
it's great news for new and current peer
12 customers pure talk just added data
to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but have not made the switch
take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot this is one of
the many reasons I love puretalk they're
veteran owned and only hire the best
customer service team located right here
in the great us of a most families are
saving almost a thousand dollars a year
while enjoying the most Dependable 5G
coverage in America
remember that you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that do not support
you
when you go to puretalk.com Knowles you
will save an additional fifty five zero
percent off your first month because
they value you puretalk.com Knowles
puretalk Wireless for Americans by
Americans
speaking of misspeaking
Kathy hokel the Democrat Governor of New
York she is not happy with all the
illegal aliens who are making it to New
York after conservative Governors like
Ron DeSantis and Greg Abbott and Texas
and others have have passed along the
great benefit of all those illegal
aliens you know that that uh wonderful
expression of diversity which is our
strength well Texas and Florida they
don't want to hog all of that wonderful
diversity for themselves they want to
pass some of it along to Martha's
Vineyard in Rehoboth Beach and to New
York and Kathy Hogle says hey hey
we didn't ask for this do you think the
city may have dropped the ball somewhat
in dealing with this crisis over a
hundred thousand migrants arriving in
New York City since spring of last year
no the mayor has had extraordinary
challenges he didn't invite all these
individuals in I think there was an
expectation that not so many would be
allowed to come to the border that
they'd relocate in other states so no
this is nothing anyone could have
anticipated and it's been an enormous
challenge we didn't ask for this no one
could have anticipated this
you literally asked for it you you and
Eric Adams and many Democrats who
preceded both of you in New York have
asked for it when you have described New
York as a sanctuary state
when you describe New York City as a
sanctuary City
that is
the same thing as telling illegal aliens
come here you're not welcome in other
parts of the country you are welcome
here please come here
but they say please come here
when they don't think that the Florida
Governors are going to help those
illegal aliens who generally don't have
a lot of money make that long Voyage
it's very easy to say please come here
when you're a thousand miles away or
more
because you think well these guys
they're probably not going to hop on a
Greyhound bus so it's going to be El
Paso's problem it's going to be Texas's
problem
until Abbott and DeSantis are chartering
flights then they come there and they
say wait we don't want this we want you
guys to have all the diversity okay
well that's the reality the reality of a
sanctuary state is this massive increase
in disorder and dysfunction and crime
and housing problems and all the rest of
it that goes along with it and I'm so
glad that that New York finally gets to
see that so closely speaking of the rule
of law
there's good news and then there's bad
news
the good news was Donald Trump was
planning a press conference at which he
was going to double down on claims of
2020 election fraud and provide a
100-page report that apparently
documents it
the bad news is he's just canceled the
press conference
because a bunch of news organizations
reported that Trump's lawyers were
advising him to cancel the event because
such an event would would expose him to
further legal consequences here is what
Trump said
he said a large complex
detailed but irrefutable report on the
presidential election fraud which took
place in Georgia
is almost complete and will be presented
by me at a major news conference at 11
A.M on Monday of next week in Bedminster
New Jersey based on the results of this
conclusive report all charges should be
dropped against me and others
there will be a complete exoneration
they never went after those that rigged
the election they only went after those
that fought to find the rigors
rigors not
r-i-g-o-r-s r-i-g-g-e-r-s
rigors
I love this I wish you did the press
conference I think it was a bad idea to
cancel it and I don't know what those
lawyers were thinking here's I know I do
know what they were thinking they were
thinking oh no Trump
ah please Mr President please shut up
about the election fraud because it's
gonna they're gonna they're gonna put
more charges on you and that's going to
complicate the 2024 election
guys I see that I get that I recognize
that Prudence is the highest political
virtue
Trump is currently facing over 700 years
in prison
there is an argument to be made based on
the the statues involved in the charges
against Trump that they could try to
execute him
okay
I don't think one more press conference
is going to hurt oh no if he has another
press conference they might try to throw
him in prison for 800 years guys it
we're so past that
and from the political side but people
are going to say just move on stop
talking about the 2020 election just
talk about the future
yeah maybe maybe
theoretically it would be better if we
could talk about 2024 rather than 2020.
they're trying to throw the guy in
prison over 2020. they're trying to
throw the current leader of the
opposition the presumptive Republican
nominee for president in prison for for
the 2020 election
it is not possible to avoid talking
about the 2020 election in 2024. but if
only we could just talk about our brand
new tax
yeah sure if my Grandma had Wheels she'd
be a wagon but you can't do that because
the election will hinge largely around
the person of trump unless something
drastically changes the election
and the candidacy of Donald Trump will
hinge largely around the multiple
indictments that he's under the hundreds
of years in prison that he's facing and
all of that is going to hinge on the
2020 election so you can't avoid it guys
it's you've got to talk about it Trump
can't run away from his claims the 2020
election was rigged the only reason he's
the presumptive nominee right now is
because he's claiming the 2020 election
was rigged
that's how he's still got Mojo to run
George H.W bush couldn't have run again
in 1996 after losing in 1992 because he
lost and everyone knew he lost with
Trump there were to my mind
very legitimate questions to be raised
about the ways the Democrats rigged the
election
but even if you don't believe that even
if you think it was a totally fair
election and the Democrats they would
never cheat or anything and they just
coincidentally changed all the rules
right before the election even if you
think that the the reason that he is a
candidate right now
and a plausible candidate is because he
can claim that the election was stolen
and a lot of people will believe it
because we have eyes and ears and we
read news reports and saw what happened
so
you can't run away from that I would
just double down I would just recognize
that the only way out is through
now speaking of trump in those poll
numbers
new poll out from NPR and Marist showing
that not only is Trump leading the pack
on the primary side of things but he is
neck and neck with Biden nationally
Biden 47 Trump 46 so statistically a tie
which is a tough argument
it's a tough fact for the people making
the argument that Trump can't possibly
win a general election and also among
Independents Trump is leading by by a
lot according to NPR Marist obviously
not a right-wing poll Trump is up eight
points among Independents over Joe Biden
then you look at the Harvard Harris poll
Trump is currently leading Biden for
president by Five Points 45 to 40 and
among Independents Trump is leading
Biden by 18 points 45 to 27.
still you're going to hear this argument
from some people who prefer other
candidates they're going to say well
Trump just can't win the general
election sure he's dominating the
primary but he can't win a general
election
what what is your evidence of that the
the only evidence of that is the 2020
election which as we've just pointed out
is hotly disputed I think legitimately
so because the Democrats changed all the
rules right before the election some of
those rules have been fortunately
changed back a little bit but who knows
maybe we're just through the Looking
Glass and we're not going to get a fair
shake for for the near future the other
reason why that argument is weak is all
the people right now who are making the
argument that Trump can't win a general
election
made the same argument in 2016.
I'm not saying it's 100 every single
person is identical to the people who
made that argument in 2016 but the
overlap is pretty substantial you can't
help but notice it
and so that argument doesn't have
credibility because all the people
making it were wrong about that argument
in 2016. he obviously can win a general
election he already did
he's now running two national elections
one with basically ordinary voting rules
one where they completely upended the
voting rules in ways that open up the
system to a lot of fraud as even Barack
Obama admitted about widespread mail-in
ballots and extending the voting period
far beyond voting day Obama made that
argument about 10 years ago before it
was advantageous for his side to do it
during covid regardless though you can't
make that argument and when you look at
these numbers again we take polls we
take all social science with a grain of
salt I don't see
how one can argue that Trump doesn't
have a shot in a in an even relatively
Fair election I'm not saying he's going
to win I'm not convinced he's going to
win at all
even if he is the nominee I'm I'm not
going to put all bet the farm on that
but to say he doesn't have a shot guys
look at the facts look at the numbers
don't don't look at what the chattering
class is saying don't don't just look at
what all the GOP genius Consultants are
saying people who have been wrong time
and time again
just look at the numbers and look at
history
that might help you sleep easier at
night
you know what else will help you sleep
easy
Helix right now go to helixsleep.com
Knowles with everything going on in the
world right now you could really use a
good night's sleep that is why you need
to check out Helix mattress Helix has
harnessed years of extensive mattress
expertise to bring their customers a
truly elevated sleep experience they
just launched their new Helix Elite the
Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models each tailored
for specific sleep positions and
firmness preferences I've had my Helix
for years now I absolutely love it night
after night I sleep like a sweet
delicate little child I want the same
for you Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress why
would you buy a mattress made for
someone else get out of my mattress I'm
a married man go to helixsleep.com
Knowles take their two-minute sleep quiz
to find the perfect mattress for your
body and sleep type their flexible
payment plans make it so that a great
night's sleep is never far away Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners hurry
over to helixsleep.com Knowles with
Helix better sleep starts
now
folks it's here
you can enjoy an all new episode of my
beloved wildly controversial interview
game show
yes or no in this latest episode I'm
joined by metal band lead singer and
comic book Guru Eric July check out this
clip
every Hollywood superhero moving forward
will be required to have at least one
lgbtq character shoved into the story
what do you mean moving forward we're
already there buddy
[Music]
don't forget you can bring the show home
yes or no the game is in stock go to
dailywire.com shop to get yours these
games go very very fast with 200 cards
and the ability to play up to nine
people at once it is easy to see why
this is the best selling and most
important game at the daily wire yes or
no hands down best way to add some
excitement to your parties challenge
your friends and Family's knowledge and
delve into the most thought provoking
topics of our time by the way the new
booster pack the booster set with brand
new cards on
conspiracy theories is here it's here
it's landed okay folks go get it if
you've already played all the game all
the cards go get some more daily
wire.com shop order yes or no today
my favorite comment yesterday from
vanilla Southpaw Michael's going soft
none of his show was censored on YouTube
today
I want to correct that okay because
that's an I see why you would think that
but that's actually not true
some of my show was censored on YouTube
it's just that our editors are so good
that they were able to splice out that
section without totally disrupting the
show but
basically every single day there will be
part sometimes if it's just a word that
I have they'll bleep it out and keep the
rest of it but if there's a segment that
YouTube says no we're going to Nuke your
whole channel for this then we cut it
out the editor's producer Danny's very
good at this the editors will cut it out
so you'll have to go to where all the
other places where the show is the RSS
feed Apple podcast Spotify Stitcher
Twitter at emnol's show The Daily wire
plus obviously
head on over there that's where you can
see the full show where I talk about all
the spicy topics that YouTube won't let
us talk about
okay
speaking of spice
and the sexual Revolution and weak
arguments like we were talking about in
there is some anti-marriage propaganda
going around on Tick Tock this video is
going everywhere I cannot ignore it any
longer if you're watching you can see it
if not I will describe you're only
listening I will describe what's
happening a pretty young girl nice
looking happy sheep puts an engagement
ring on on the wrong hand actually
and every time she she puts it on she's
she sees a vision of herself cooking
cleaning being barefoot and pregnant
holding a baby you're working so hard
and she puts it down she says no thank
you I'm out I'm out don't need that
don't want marriage
and the thing about this clip
people are saying
on the one hand
this is not true this is not true that's
not what marriage is like at all
and on the other hand obviously people
on the other side are saying that is
what marriage is that's why you got to
flee and the reality of this clip of
this anti-marriage propaganda is
it's half true
it's half true in that when you get
married
you will be
cooking and cleaning and if you're a
good wife you'll be cooking and cleaning
and having babies and taking care of the
babies and keeping a home and you'll be
doing you will be doing all those things
some some are pointing out well you're
doing a lot of those things anyway even
if you're not married you know cooking
and cleaning at the very least doing
laundry yeah that's true but it's not
even
in the same Stratosphere okay when you
the amount of just laundry that exists
when you have even one baby
not that I know much about this it's not
like I've ever done probably a single
load of laundry at my house but I see it
I see my wife my wife does a lot of it
she works very very hard but that's
that's true you do all of that
and there is joy that comes from that
the the real answer to this
anti-marriage propaganda is what else
would you be doing
and the setting for the video is so
perfectly telling here because it's it's
at a nice looking little brunch spot
that's where it is nice little outdoor
patio Cafe sitting at a table that's
where the guy's proposing and that is
the alternative
if you don't want to get married if you
don't want to have a baby if you don't
want to commit to religious life and
marriage isn't for everybody if you
don't want to consecrate your single
Hood to something greater than your own
pursuit of pleasure
then you're just going to have a lot of
brunch and you know what in at every
single discreet moment
the brunch is going to seem more
pleasant than getting married and having
a baby and raising a family
until it's not at all
until it's misery inducing and Until you
realize that the family is this
joy that that I couldn't even possibly
Express
so you get I get home from work
I've been on the road
I've been working hard my wife she's
been working very hard we sit down we're
just so bone tired and then the kids
come over and they they do something
that's like demanding more of our energy
and attention just like I can't go I
just want to sit and watch an episode
and I just want to go eat brunch
somewhere I mean and then your little
kid just says something or just looks at
you and just kind of giggles and smiles
or something and your heart swells up
it's so great what are you gonna do
you're going to do something in your
life
and so then the question becomes deeper
the question is is the point of your
life to receive a lot of pleasure to
feel really Pleasant all the time
or whether we're talking about material
pleasure whether we're talking about
pursuing your career ambition or
something like that or
do you have more of a verb do you have a
biological purpose
does your body imply a purpose
does the fact that you're a social
creature and a complementary creature
and that that uh in the words of Thomas
Aquinas human beings are pairing
creatures so men are for women and women
are for men does that
point you towards something that will be
more fulfilling you're right lady if you
get married you're going to work a lot
harder than you're working now as some
bubbly little feminist 22 year old girl
eating brunch that's true you'll also
live a much happier life
work is not the enemy okay sloth will
not make you happy
mimosas will not make you happy at least
not for very long speaking of women's
issues
and stories that I almost certainly will
not be able to talk about on YouTube
I'm just going to read the headline I'm
not even gonna
I'm not even going to introduce it the
headline is
[Music]
speaking of
speaking of what to do with your body
and how to chop parts of it off
you know you obviously don't want to
chop off organs or anything like that
but you do need to chop off your stubble
don't you of course you do if you want
to look clean and shaven and smart
that's why you got to give your son and
his values a fighting chance with
Jeremy's back to college deals get up to
20 off select razors and men's care
bundles get Jeremy's shampoo body wash
and conditioner
all paraben free sulfate free woke free
made here in the US of a
get him a Precision five razor with
welded steel blades a sturdy tungsten
handle and flip back trimmer
unlike your kids radical professors
Jeremy's aims to groom his face not his
beliefs go to jeremy'srazors.com take
advantage of the last day of this sale
now speaking of
dishonesty oh are we at the mailbag
already we've made it oh my gosh
goodness gracious we're already at the
mailbag I have so many more things to
get to that'll just be my tease for this
weekend or maybe we'll talk about it in
all access today but now
this mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk
go to puretalk.com
50 off your first month
take it away
hi Michael Arun here username Arun
parody in the chat uh first of all I am
not the real Arun I just happened to
share his voice face home address bank
account social security number parents
and wife but I'm not him never even met
the guy anyway I'm calling in to discuss
the issue of space aliens on which you
and Matt Walsh both of whom I love no
homo have taken equally absurd positions
on opposite ends of the spectrum as I
understand it you object to the
existence of intelligent aliens because
the existence of such an intelligent
non-human race would preclude your
belief that Jesus is the savior of all
mankind I.E the children of Adam now I'm
familiar with the New Testament and the
particulars of Roman Catholic theology
and I disagree with your claim that
these are mutually exclusive assertions
and I say this as someone who doesn't
believe in Jesus I merely believe that
the existence of aliens is unrelated to
the question of whether Jesus is the
savior of mankind and I'm curious to
hear you expand on why you believe
otherwise now on the other hand Matt
Walsh starts with the very reasonable
premise that intelligent life evolved on
other planets as it did here I think
that this is statistically likely and as
a Hindu I believe that any such life was
created by God with Immortal Souls that
are subject to the law of karma however
matters in my opinion by expressing the
inane proposition that UFOs which in all
likelihood are radar blips and optical
illusions are in fact aliens that have
managed to breach the light speed
barrier and come here only to prank us
by hinting at their presence without
revealing themselves it's far more
likely that this narrative is
promulgated by the Democrats to distract
from the many crimes of the Biden family
who should be prosecuted under the very
Rico laws that are being weaponized
against Donald Trump at the moment
anyway I'd love to hear your thoughts on
this and if you think there can be a
middle ground between yours and Matt's
current position on Aliens thank you as
always for your wisdom
Arun is always very articulately stated
you you totally get to it and I totally
agree with you on Matt I also my view
has been slightly caricatured I think
which is that people say that I think
that all the alien sightings are demons
or something which is not my view my
view is that probably a lot of it is as
you say optical illusions little radar
blips uh and the government's trying to
cover up various weapons programs though
I do think that some of it inasmuch as
people do see shadowy little gray
figures uh very possibly could be demons
which I certainly think exist as as
virtually everybody for all of human
history uh now to the the question of
the statistical likelihood I guess this
is where we disagree because
in order to ascertain the statistical
likelihood of Life existing elsewhere in
the universe we would have to know
something about how life arises in the
first place and there are people who
hold
deeply deeply held religious belief in
in some theory of evolution or other who
believe that life arises just naturally
or inevitably is a process of complexity
over time develops amid I don't know I
don't know what
I don't know what because nobody knows
what because no one has ever shown the
natural process by which we go from
inorganic to organic but from which we
go to in inanimate I should say
inanimate to animate I just don't I've
never seen it
so it would seem to me to me at least
that the development of life is much
much much more special that it's not the
inevitable product of some natural
process
so therefore if it were the latter then
the vastness of the universe might imply
that statistically it would be likely
that life would arise elsewhere but if
it's the former as I believe or at least
as I have no reason not to believe then
if the universe could be 50 gazillion
times larger than it already is and that
would still not imply anything about the
statistical likelihood of Life arising
anywhere else in the world the other
reason just from the Christian
perspective is
we hear about a lot of different things
in the Bible all sorts of things we
don't know much about Leviathan Nephilim
principalities and power spiritual
wickedness in high places orders of
angels demons all sorts of things
don't don't you think if there were
little green men out there somewhere
that might have popped up
I know it seems like a pretty glaring
Omission to say nothing about what it
implies for salvation history so anyway
as usual Arun
I deeply respect your points but I'm
afraid
the most
insightful part of your question was
when you pointed out that Matt Walsh is
wrong next question
hello Michael big fan I just watched
your interview with Tracy Shannon and
while I can't help but feel terrible for
what happened to her and her children
there were a couple things in there that
really did not sit right with me
Tracy refers to being asked by her
husband to do some unusual things in the
bedroom as quote sexual abuse and
coercion to me this is an extremely
grave false accusation the smacks of the
metoo movement and I was hoping you
would push back on this claim a little
bit more
conservative movement I hope we can
distinguish going forward between a
false belief that up ends your entire
life and causes you to not be able to
fulfill your duties to your children and
a bizarre sexual fetish that is kept
relatively within its proper place
inside the bedroom
this obviously was not kept to the
bedroom but speaking as a Catholic who
himself struggles with some pretty
severe fetishism I'm very thankful that
my own is not the kind that will compel
me to grievously hurt others or to upend
my own life but there but for the grace
of God go I
know your advice to me might be simply
knock it off and be normal but as you
know this is much easier said than done
I hope that God willing if I ever were
to get married and gathered the courage
to explain my desires to my wife and to
open up to her about them that she would
be receptive or at least understanding
and patient with me not threaten me with
divorce or accuse me of something
tantamount to rape
like Tracy Shannon did am I being too
harsh on her here please let me know
your thoughts Michael thanks you are you
are being too harsh and it's a very good
question but
you but you're wrong and and
you're wrong in the way that unmarried
guys are wrong because you're saying
look I've got all these bizarre sexual
desires and I just hope that my wife
accommodates them someday
that is not the Catholic view of sex
the Catholic view of sex is that sex has
a purpose okay and the purpose is not
just to indulge whatever fantasies you
have even if you say Well they're not
violent fantasies they're just some
other kind of fantasy right even that
not a great idea the other the other
reason you're wrong here is because you
are viewing desire at in in the way that
Freud might view desire which is that
you got to blow off a little steam and
if you don't indulge some of these
desires then they're going to totally
warp your mind and go go out of control
that's very different from the
Aristotelian view of desire which is
that it's a habit and so you cultivate
habits and the more you indulge say
these sexual fetishes and desires that
you have that's not going to alleviate
those desires it's going to exacerbate
them it's going to make it worse
actually so the best thing that you can
do is try to Tamp them down a little bit
and obviously in a way that is prudent
uh you want to try to turn your desire
it's a fallen world and we're subject to
concupiscence so it's probably not going
to totally work but you should try to
turn your desire toward that which is
properly ordered and and you will find
this is not just a sex thing this is
true of all disorder desires you will
find that those disorder disorder
desires Abate at least to some degree uh
if as you say you struggle with these
desires now I don't know I'm not
accusing you of looking at pornography
or anything like that or even
fantasizing but don't forget even the
willful entertainment of of disordered
and uh impure and unchaste thoughts and
desires even that is a sin if you do it
willfully and so you should really work
on that because the basic reason is
because sex is not about just you and
fulfilling your pleasure sex is about
the other person your spouse one hopes
and about fully giving of yourself to
the other person not merely you know
titillating yourself and doing that in
such a way that the love between you two
becomes so real that it creates another
person okay
next question yeah to put a button on
hello Michael hold on pause that
question to put a button on them
uh no
no husband or wife has the right to
the Indulgence of of some disordered
sexual desire by his spouse or her
husband uh
for the purpose of of pure pleasure I
mean that that's a very modern view of
sex it's not a not a Christian view of
sex next question
hello Michael this is Brian coming to
you from a village named after a word
derived from the Native American
language meaning mud turtle you
mentioned in the past you would like to
have a deeper cigar discussion on your
program I do need your cigar expertise
what is your protocol after you have
enjoyed a fine cigar in a delicious
beverage and you want to have some
romance with sweet little lease and you
go up to her and she says Mark get away
from
our breath my question to you is when I
would like to get fresh with the bride
of my youth after enjoying a Monte
Cristo white series and a delicious
beverage what can I do to prevent from
hearing Brian get away from me with that
it's filthy cigar breath
I appreciate all you do continue being
Delight anytime you're blowing through
the windy city let me know we can have a
chat over Monte Cristo take care bye
a beautifully stated question
you have the cigar afterward
that's that's the real answer you know
uh you're the head of your household
you call the shots ultimately
but Prudence is an important we keep
Prudence keeps coming up today Prudence
is an important virtue and The Prudent
thing to do is
save the cigar for the end of the night
that's what you do we have more
voicemail back to get to we've got more
written mail back together too we've got
fake headline Friday there's a lot to do
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code Noel skin awas at check out for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh